buenas tardes les voy a hacer una
pregunta os voy a hacer una pregunta a
quien le gusta que le llamen oportunista
levanten la mano
a nadie voy a ver si consigo que cambie
esa forma de pensar hace unos años un
antiguo socio en una discusión me dijo
tú no eres un creador
alguien que hace algo nuevo tú lo que
eres es una oportunista y aquello mis
amigos recapacitar y darme cuenta de que
era verdad de que tenía esa gran virtud
y que tenía que aprovecharla al máximo
para mis dos tipos de personas o
emprendedores unos son los que tienen
grandes ideas ideas disruptoras que
nadie más ha tenido y que las
desarrollan para crear un gran producto
otros son los que estudian esas ideas y
ven las ineficiencias que tienen ven
como mejorarlas ven
e incluso productos alternativos o
complementarios que pueden hacer para
conseguir un resultado aún mejor ese
tipo de personas son los oportunistas
el mundo está lleno de ineficiencias
son productos que no están bien
terminados que no funcionan todo bien
que deben estar hechos por humanos que
nos equivocamos y el oportunista tiene
que saber encontrar esas ineficiencias y
aprovecharlas al máximo tiene que ser
rápido para encontrarlas y rápido para
ejecutarlas porque esas ineficiencias se
acaban no son permanentes eso hace que
la vida del oportunista pues sea muy
dura porque estás continuamente pues
teniendo altibajos o estás de subidón
porque has encontrado una gran
oportunidad y las estás explotando al
máximo
se está acabando tu oportunidad la
ineficiencia se está solucionando y te
quedas sin tu gran obra de arte entonces
tienes que seguir trabajando para
encontrar la próxima oportunidad hay un
símil que me gusta mucho que es el del
surf pero un surfero para la cresta de
la ola está disfrutando su vida y viendo
el paisaje y que viene estoy arriba y la
ola va bajando entonces lo que tiene que
hacer es empezar a mirar a su alrededor
buscar la siguiente ola y saltar a ella
antes de que caiga la que está ahora
mismo
por suerte el mundo está lleno de olas o
el mar está lleno de olas y se crean
continuamente que pueden surgir
problemas éticos muchas veces tienes que
estar la línea gris entre lo que está
bien o lo que está mal
de hecho la definición de oportunista es
la persona que se aprovecha de
situaciones por encima de principios o
de ética por eso la charla le ha llamado
el buen oportunista porque es verdad que
te puedes desviar y tener la tentación
de ir al lado oscuro pero eso acaba mal
o sea a corto plazo te puede funcionar
pero es verdad que a largo plazo
acaba siendo un problema y no lo
recomiendo el oportunista tiene dos
atributos principales el primero es la
eficiencia todo se puede hacer más
rápido mejor y de una forma más
eficiente el otro gran atributo es la
curiosidad para ser un oportunista
tienes que estar si eres el surfero
tienes que ir al mar a buscar las olas
en este caso el oportunista tiene que
hacer lo mismo tiene que estar
continuamente mirando a su alrededor
descubriendo esas oportunidades esas
ineficiencias en los sistemas o en los
productos de los demás para conseguir
explotar lás es verdad que es agotador
que es muy dura la vida del oportunista
pero también es verdad que con el tiempo
pues te vas endureciendo y te vas dando
cuenta de que bueno en los momentos
altos no tienes que estar tan contento
ni confiarte demasiado y en los momentos
malos tampoco tienes que preocuparte
porque sabes que eres capaz porque lo
has hecho más veces de volver a
conseguir hacer algo bien entonces bueno
es verdad que eso que te vuelves más
frío o como queramos llamarlo y es algo
que tienes que transmitir también a tus
empleados y a sus socios porque al final
quieres que te acompañen contigo
no se confíen demasiado en los momentos
buenos ni tampoco se desanimen en los
momentos malos en cuanto a la curiosidad
como digo tienes que estar rodeado
continuamente de estímulos que te harán
ver las nuevas oportunidades
es muy importante viajar y conocer el
mundo ir a eventos o bien de tu sector o
incluso a otros sectores donde puedes
ver otras ideas hablar con gente
relacionarte todo lo que puedas y sobre
todo algo muy importante es ampliar tu
red de contactos
yo considero el conseguir contactos a
nivel laboral o personal como el que va
por el campo sembrando semillas que
algún día puedes ir recogiendo y de
hecho así es nunca sabes cuándo las vas
a necesitar pero esas personas que has
ido conociendo pues en algún momento se
pueden cruzar en tu vida y facilitarte
pues algún trabajo o alguna oportunidad
nueva de negocio el oportunista puede
pensar muchas veces que lo puede hacer
todo solo sobre todo si tiene éxito al
principio pues puede pensar bonito nadie
me va a todo bien
soy maravilloso pero eso no es así a
corto plazo puede funcionar a largo
plazo nunca funciona tienes que rodearte
de las personas adecuadas
para mí hay dos tipos de personas unos
son los que llamaríamos los cazadores
que serían los inventores o los
oportunistas que son capaces de buscar
ideas nuevas y de desarrollarlas y por
otro lado están los granjeros que serían
los trabajadores que si bien no son tan
brillantes a la hora de encontrar esas
ideas sí que son pues trabajadores
incansables ordenados
que sigue en una línea hasta que
terminan y son imprescindibles igual a
la hora de trabajar a la hora de buscar
tus socios pues obviamente tienes que
encontrar ese balance entre cazadores y
granjeros si te juntas con otro cazador
muy divertido las tormentas de ideas en
las reuniones pues son una pasada estás
continuamente pensando en cosas nuevas
que hacer nuevos negocios pero el
problema es cuando estás continuamente
pensando en qué hacer qué divertido y al
final no haces nada que es algo muy
típico cuando se juntan varios
oportunistas o varios inventores
quien te puede dar ese balance o cuál es
la opción conservadora buscarte un socio
granjero que si bien no es tan brillante
como tú para encontrar esa idea sí que
va a ser el que te va ayudar a
ejecutarla a aprovechar los recursos al
máximo ya conseguir que llegues al final
sin desviarse de tu camino y sin
distraerte
eso mismo aplica también a los empleados
a la hora de buscar empleados pues
también hay que buscar ese balance entre
cazadores y granjeros dependiendo del
sector necesitarán más de un tipo de
otro pero al final sí que tienes que
tener ese balance
unos que te ayuden a encontrar esas
ideas y otros sobre todo que las
ejecuten que precisamente son del
oportunista pues no es tan bueno
esos empleados es muy importante
buscarlos mucho pensar en que necesitas
cómo tienen que ser sobre todo hay que
buscar no el conocimiento que también
pero sí sobre todo la actitud bo
rodearte de gente que en el futuro de
verdad esté a tu lado que empuje que en
los momentos buenos que como oportunista
sabes que vas a tener no se crea que lo
pueda conseguir todo ni que los malos
pues te deje plantado porque no tiene la
energía suficiente para superar ese
problema
yo soy mucho del dicho que aunque suena
un poco feo de ser muy lento contratando
y muy rápido despidiendo eso que
significa pues que como he dicho hay que
analizar mucho a las personas a las que
contratas como trabajadores pero también
si descubres que una persona no es la
adecuada porque mantenerla como pasa en
muchos puestos de trabajo cuando esa
persona ni ni es feliz haciendo lo que
hace sufre porque la gente cuando no
cumple bien su labor sufrimos
y por otro lado pues a ti es una carga
económica que en el fondo es una
ineficiencia que es lo que trata de
solucionar entonces en ese caso es mejor
despedir a esa persona que tengas ya con
su futuro y tú contratar a las adecuadas
eso influye mucho también la formación
una vez que encuentras a las personas
adecuadas si has encontrado sobre todo
la actitud correcta te falta que tengan
el conocimiento es básico que les formes
y que te formes tú con ellos y más para
el oportunista que está continuamente
buscando nueva línea de negocio y
aprendiendo cosas nuevas también la
formación va a hacer que estén más
motivados y de sean más fieles hay un
dicho que leí una vez una red social que
decían eran dos directivos que le decía
uno al otro y si contratamos a un
empleado y le enseñamos todo lo que
sabemos se vuelve muy bueno y nos acaba
dejando y el otro le dice y si no le
enseñamos nada acaba siendo malo y se
queda para mí eso es eso es clave
entonces no puedes tener ese miedo a
formar a gente que se vaya
como consigues que esa gente se quede
contigo pues lo principal es ser un buen
líder y un buen líder no es ser un jefe
el típico jefe que tenemos la idea que
tiene la gente asustada con miedo y con
una exigencia por encima de lo normal la
gente va a querer abandonar a ese líder
el líder que tenemos que ser es el es el
ejemplo del sargento de las películas
que va con los soldados en primera línea
que se mete en la trinchera que se
arremanga que acaba con ellos que se
llena de barro y que lo da todo que
duerme con los compañeros no en la
retaguardia ese es el tipo de líder que
hay que ser porque es el líder que se
convierte en un mentor incluso a veces
en un amigo es al que los empleados no
van a dejar solo los momentos malos que
como he dicho van a llegar eso es clave
para para mantenerlos
también hay un algo que me dijo un
empleado que se me quedó grabado que me
dijo tú eres mucho más duro con tus
hijos que con dos empleados y les tratas
les hablas más fuerte y demás y es
cierto pero si yo tuviese que tratar a
mis empleados como a mis hijos de 6 y 11
años significaría que algo hecho mal a
contratarles entonces
está claro que lo que hay que buscar es
la gente que se comporte como adultos
que parece les has contratado pero para
ello que darles también
esa libertad para equivocarse que se
equivoquen como tú que aprendan de sus
equivocaciones hombre si se equivocan
continuamente pues habrá que
recordárselo un poco más pero sí que que
sea gente autosuficiente porque para mí
el micro control de los empleados es una
pérdida de tiempo brutal y estamos
hablando de ser eficientes
entonces el estar cada día diciendo una
persona aprieta este botón para eso lo
aprietas tú o sea lo que se trata es de
que la gente tenga la autonomía
suficiente y el conocimiento para ser
capaces de ser independientes tú estarás
ahí a alto nivel para dar ciertas
instrucciones o estrategias pero ellos
tienen que ser lo que los que ejecutan
eso también hará pues que se sientan
importantes motivados y quieran seguir a
tu lado como he dicho en los momentos
difíciles o que no lo en algún momento
bueno como decía antes en el dicho pues
sean tan buenos que se quieran ir
y como resumen diría que en esta vida
tenemos que ser oportunistas en el
sentido de la palabra y la mayor
oportunidad que tenemos somos nosotros
mismos el poder mejorarnos el ser más
eficientes más rápidos mejores como he
dicho es algo que podemos conseguir si
se consigue cada día con las pequeñas
cosas pequeñas metas que te pones
disfrutar con cada cosa que haces de
esta charla por ejemplo pues para mí es
una oportunidad para aprender a hablar
en público me pongo nervioso con esto
consigo mejorar para vosotros es una
oportunidad también el estar aquí yo
escuchar a gente diciendo cosas
graciosas o interesantes y hay que
buscar así oportunidades en todo en la
vida porque de verdad las personas somos
la mayor oportunidad de mejora que hay y
la que más vamos a aprovechar en nuestra
vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]